after months of high-stakes negotiations
the Trump Kim summit is finally back on
that's right Kim Kardashian is coming to
the White House she's gonna be talking
about criminal justice reform I know
that's the Kim summit you've all been
waiting for we will analyze the
political and philosophical
ramifications of the Kim summit there's
actually a lot to see here and a lot of
new directions for the administration
then Allie Stuckey will stop by to give
me advice on love and sex and marriage
and children at least at three three of
those four we will get to her and we'll
talk about other things as well and then
we will have the mailbag because I'm
going away on my honeymoon for a week
and I wanted people to talk to you you
people you people who might love so much
I want to be able to talk to you before
I go away I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
before we get to the Kim Summit before
we get to the Kim Kardashian summit I
guess we still have to talk about
Roseanne right we still have to talk
about it Roseanne has been trending on
Twitter for the last 48 hours just
consecutively and listen I get it you
know she's actually been pretty gracious
about all this she says don't try to
defend my tweet it's indefensible it's a
bad joke I'm sorry I said I didn't mean
oh whatever right
the thing I really don't want us to lose
sight of while everybody is criticizing
Roseanne is that Valerie Jarrett is a
terrible person I don't want us to fall
into this trap conservatives fall into
this trap
where we really don't want Democrats to
call us racists so then we tried it when
now we're like defending Valerie Jarrett
Valerie Jarrett is awful just a quick
little run down she was the top personal
aide to Barack Obama for his entire
presidency and really before the
presidency she goes back in Chicago a
long ways with Barack and Michelle the
Obama White House these are people who
work for Barack Obama referred to her as
the nightstalker
she who must not be challenged she would
follow the Obamas into the private
residence at night and keep talking to
them Rahm Emmanuel Barack Obama's chief
of staff regularly referred to Valerie
Jarrett alternately as day and cou say
Hussein they did not have AI opinion of
her she had a staff of three dozen and
she did everything from decide who goes
to state dinners to what gifts should be
given to foreign heads of state she
might have been behind the idea of Obama
giving Queen Elizabeth a pod an iPod
full of his own speeches who knows but
she also was in charge of the advising
on who should be nominated to the
Supreme Court advising on who should be
appointed as certain ambassadors really
a wide breadth of power she was
considered effectively the chief of
staff that's why she butted heads with
all of Obama's chiefs of staff it was
her idea to appoint Van Jones 9/11 truth
or Van Jones to Tua's our position at
the White House she pushed Solyndra at
the White House she got Barack Obama to
give a speech at cilinder Solyndra ed
core
she helped crush American business when
she was the White House liaison to the
business community who obviously the
Obama White House was terrible on
business she was the main liaison there
Larry Summers by the way agreed with
that
another Obama official agreed with that
when Valerie Jarrett comes from Chicago
she is a crony corrupt Chicago
politician on the order of Barack Obama
but only more so so when she was in
Chicago she was the CEO of this crony
Democrat Chicago real estate firm called
the habitat company when she was CEO of
the habitat company Valerie Jarrett
built some of the worst public housing
slums in the entire country many of
those required federal intervention to
fix she was practically a slumlord in
2011 a Valerie Jarrett disrespected a
four-star general because she was in an
event with him and she ordered a drink
from him she wanted him to
she thought that he was a waiter or
something like that I'm gonna keep going
on because there's a lot more to say
about Valerie Jarrett but before we do
that I have to thank candid company
candid Co candid go is really really
good you might notice as as I'm
describing you know all of these awful
political things I'm smiling and you see
my pearly whites you see either nice and
in line there they're white and
everything I have to thank candid CO
candid is helping people gain confidence
through accessible and affordable
orthodontic care candid makes the
process of straightening your teeth
convenient and easy by having the
customer take the process into their own
hands even though the customer is taking
the process into their own hands there
are these highly trained orthodontists
at candids Network and that they review
each and every case and direct the
entire aligner plan when I was a kid
when we were all were kids orthodontics
were very very expensive you had to go
to doctor visits all the time candid is
an amazing solution to your orthodontic
troubles you get straighter and brighter
teeth in an average of six months and
candid costs sixty-five percent less
than braces no office visits needed I
know look I'm a millennial I don't want
to leave my chair ever I don't want to
do anything that takes more than five
minutes ever candid makes that possible
you don't have to go to the orthodontist
office the clear aligners are sent
directly to your home they are
customized specifically for you to
straighten your teeth they they fix
crooked teeth crowding protrusions and
gaps it's really important think think
of how you waste money in your life on
things that don't matter at all that one
affects your quality of life and then
think for a relatively very low price
you can have a nice shiny set of teeth
you know a nice well aligned set of
teeth I go to the orthodontist
frequently until candid now candid
really fills that need it's really
really good you get a real worth of
dontist that's the main reason that that
you can pick candid you know other
companies they use dental professionals
they don't but candid is really is the
real deal you are one step away from
getting straighter whiter teeth like
little old me take advantage of candids
risk free modeling kit guarantee plus
when you use my dedicated link candid
co.com slash co thehm a CoV fe fe and
you'll get candid cough fa with that do
you will save 25% on your modeling kit
that is candid code gum slash cough fa c
OV e fe fe to get 25% off the price of
your modeling kit candid co.com / cough
fa okay back to Valerie Jared backed out
terrible she is because now
conservatives are defending Valerie
Jarrett like a bunch of dum-dums
so she was practically a slumlord when
she was the head of that company habitat
company in Chicago uh if she demanded a
full security detail when she was in the
White House even though it wasn't quite
clear what her job was other than just
being a powerful person behind the
scenes lasted the entire presidency she
demanded a full security detail a lot of
Obama aides said it was for simple
prestige she was a flatterer she's a
crony she's got long-standing ties to
the Muslim Brotherhood spoken as a
keynote at Muslim Brotherhood affiliated
organization national events so many of
her family were anti American radical
Communists associated with communists
that she her family members were under
FBI surveillance for that reason stop
defending Valerie Jarrett stop it a lot
of conservatives are saying right now
that we we have to disavow Roseann we
have to call her Hitler we have to say
Rosanna's a neo-nazi and she's terrible
and I hate her and her no-good stinkin
dog too otherwise Democrats will call us
racist that's what they say and this is
the worst
logic of conservatives it is such weak
sauce don't do it
who cares if a Democrat calls you a
racist you know what you know why I
don't care when Democrats call me a
racist because I'm not a racist because
I don't despise people because of their
race I don't want to discriminate
against people because of their race so
I don't care when Democrats say that a
key to a happy life is not caring what
your political opponents say who cares
what Democrats say about you they have
no moral authority they have no
credibility
I do not care they can slap me on the
back and call me Charlie for all I care
it doesn't matter I am NOT a racist I
don't care what Democrats say who they
are morally bankrupt Democrats I would
much rather be called a racist than a
Democrat by the way because a Democrat
is an actual racist right who I mean
that is one of the worst epithets you
can call somebody is Democrat they're
morally bankrupt what their their their
words on this matter have no effect stop
sucking up to them stop trying to get
your approval they're going to call you
all manner of evil things regardless of
what you do be good do the right thing
don't you know discriminate against
people because of their race don't hate
people because of their race and don't
care what Democrats say it's very very
foolish okay let's get into the big news
of the day Kim is coming to the White
House we thought those we thought these
peace talks had all broken down but no
can't the supreme leader kim kardashian
is coming to the White House that
cultural dictator Kim Kardashian is
gonna make it to the White House I am
obviously you might have thought I was
talking about the little fat guy in
Korea I am absolutely not we were
talking about another global scourge Kim
Kardashian she will be coming for
comment right now we turn to North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un why is
everyone so stupid
why aren't more people intelligent
Rockne I'm so lonely so lonely so lonely
and sad real Road gave no one just me
only sitting on my rear telephone I work
very hard
got my friends but nobody listens no one
seems right no one takes me see
[Music]
and so I'm Rory
but with a round ring
already
me
[Music]
sad that's really sad that's really
heartbreaking to see well we're gonna
get into what this Kim Kardashian talk
means plus we'll have some mailbag and
talking to Allie Stuckey because this
Kim Kardashian talk actually really does
matter and and we should pay attention
because it's not just a little sideshow
it is it is an important piece of policy
that's going on right now before all of
that I got to tell you about dynatrap I
love dynatrap dynatrap has
revolutionized my home summertime is
officially upon us the only thing more
annoying than all of these people that
I'm talking about you know little
Rocketman and all of this more annoying
than that valerie jarrett ER who knows
are the flies mosquitoes and other
insects that are invading your home so
we've got to thank our sponsors over a
dynatrap we have a bit of a fly problem
in southern california and i know you
think you know what that means but you
don't really I walk in and it's just a
swarm it's just a solid mass of flies in
Southern California these things
dynatrap these amazing fly lights the
indoor fly light you plug it in I have a
couple in my apartment they work like a
charm they look good they don't look
like a flytrap they look really nice and
they elegant on the wall and they really
really work it is the only effective
solution to this problem I've ever used
so I'm personally indebted to them and
I've asked them for more of their of
their indoor fly fly light because it's
so good the dynatrap fly light looks
like a subtle nightlight of plugs into
any indoor outlet the dynatrap fly light
works day and night to attract and trap
fly lights it really really works right
now go to dynatrap comm that is dy n8 e
ra p comm and enter the promo code daily
wired Dai ly WI r e I bet you already
knew how to spell that one receive 15%
off of any of their products and buy
their products because they're really
really good dynatrap the safe silent and
simple solution to household insect
control and most importantly the
solution that doesn't look like a bunch
of ugly flies around your apartment it
looks so elegant and nice get it okay so
we're running low on time here but I'm
gonna fly through these Kim Kardashian
what's she going to the White House to
talk about she's going there to meet
with Jared Kushner
that prison reform criminal justice
reform this is something this is one of
these issues that lefties are pushing
and conservatives who want to seem like
cool guys and get approval from the left
they are pretending is important now to
criminal justice reform what it really
means is letting criminals out of prison
when you hear criminal justice reform
usually what you're hearing is let's let
bad guys out of prison so anyway Kim
Kardashian wants to go and talk to
Kushner about this but a part of the
reason that Kushner really cares about
this issue is that Jarrod Kushner's
father went to prison for tax evasion
illegal campaign contributions witness
tampering
when Kushner was a younger younger boy
and so now he wants to get Republicans
to back letting criminals out of prison
so Kushner is pushing this bill called
the first-step Act the first-step Act
this is what Kushner said it illustrates
a total misunderstanding of this issue
but we can explain why that is he says
if we start showing that we can make the
prisons more purposeful and more
effective at lowering the recidivism
rate over time that may help the people
who are trying to make the argument for
sentencing reform so Trump said he would
sign this bill it just passed the House
overwhelmingly three 6259 this is where
Jared Kushner's Democrat Court is
showing and I hope Republicans don't
fall for this so it's the first step act
right and it what they do in DC is they
make these acts they ads like these very
long acronyms so it's the formerly
incarcerated reenter society transformed
safely transitioning every person Act
what it does is it gives out goodtime
credits to prison inmates and it can cut
a week per year off of their sentence
but it works retroactively Lee so there
are going to be people who when this
passes they'll just get out of jail
immediately it's gonna be a
get-out-of-jail-free card they also are
now proposing a quarter billion dollars
in extra spending for educational and
rehabilitative programs for these
inmates and the Kushner explained the
core of this issue the core of this
total misunderstanding by he said quote
the single biggest thing we want to do
is really define what the purpose of a
prison is is the purpose to punish is
the purpose to warehouser is the purpose
to rehabilitate yeah
while all of those things that's the
purpose I know what he wants us to say
is that it's just to rehabilitate that's
what he wants he says it was just a
rehabilitate this gets to a fundamental
misunderstanding of the purpose of
prison and of justice there are three
kinds of punishment retributive
punishment deterrence and rehabilitation
those are those are the three purposes
of punishment and of our prison system
to exact retribution for crimes that
were committed to deter and to
rehabilitate but now we only ever talked
about the latter two and really just the
last one we really only talked about
prison as therapy is that we're sending
them to some nice to turks and caicos so
they can work out their problems we're
talking about criminals no you're
punishing them mercy to the guilty is
cruelty to the innocent as Adam Smith
said criminal justice I talked to a lot
of people in this field in the criminal
justice field
criminologists I kid you not I said I
asked them what's the purpose of
criminal justice and almost uniformly
they they say it's sometimes deterrent
and to rehabilitate they don't talk
about the retributive aspect but I say
okay well that's criminal justice huh
that's your explanation so where does
the justice come in does justice have
anything to do with criminal justice
they say oh I kid you not I've talked to
people who have PhDs in this they say
I've never thought about that before
I've never thought that criminal justice
maybe should have anything to do with
justice and we're totally missing this
we're missing this now because our a
ability to discuss questions about
virtue and morality and the moral order
in the metaphysical world is so so
weakened it's it's become so as so
degraded and it's a decayed so much that
we don't even know that that's a
possibility there's another large push
now on so-called criminal justice reform
to treat 21 year old criminals as though
they are children they want that them to
be tried in juvenile courts 21 year old
commits some heinous crime oh he's just
a kid he's just a kid isn't he is I mean
now we have 30 year olds living with
their parents and refusing to be evicted
so I suppose maybe that's they maybe
there should be 30 year olds next they
all say oh my brain made me do it this
is why we don't punish people anymore is
because we're trying to defer moral
responsibility we say I'm not
responsible for my actions it was
society it was my circumstances it was
poverty
it was a lack of education or finally
which is what we've gotten to you my
brain made me do it I just couldn't
control myself just my brain the random
physical material synapses in my brain
just made me commit the crime so you
can't punish me because that's true if
materialism is true then you certainly
shouldn't punish anybody for a crime
they have no moral culpability they
could walk up and slit your throat it's
not how dare you punish them they didn't
do it their brain made them do it so
this is the the morally idiotic and
practically idiotic aspect of so-called
criminal justice reform it morally it
doesn't make any sense it's totally
incoherent you know now we're referring
we don't call people juvenile
delinquents anymore the new term is
justice involved youth that's the Obama
era term which is ironic because they're
explicitly injustice engulfed youth but
you listen if we quibbled about every
word we'd be here for the next for my
entire honeymoon it doesn't make sense
it's morally idiotic it's also
practically idiotic people say we have
too many people in prison in America do
we I don't know is our crime rate zero
then I know that then I think we have
too few people in prison in America
don't we there was that famous headline
in the New York Times Fox Butterfield
wrote it it was something to the effect
of the crime continued crime rate
continues to fall
despite prisons filling he's a disco
dine so you're locking up all of the
criminals and the criminal crime rate is
falling yeah that's probably despite
that's probably the word I would use to
describe it dummies of the New York
Times so anyway Tom cotton opposes this
Tom cotton has basically exactly the
view that I have
we don't have an overpopulation problem
in prison we have an under population
problem in prison we need to lock up
more criminals and we need to stop
pretending that people don't have any
moral culpability whatsoever it is it is
a recipe for social disaster let's get
to the mailbag in the remaining few
minutes I don't know I'm gonna have to
ask the control room how many more
minutes I have to get through these
mailbag questions I'll try to fly
through them the first question is from
Evan a dear soon to be shackled Michael
Knowles will the daily wire be live
streaming the blessed day Evan you know
that we were going to livestream at the
blessed night but I got such a negative
reaction to my Valentine's Day promotion
video with the short little smoking
jacket and my dainty little legs that I
I didn't want to subject myself to that
sort of insulting criticism again so no
we won't be live-streaming the day or
the night so there so there Evan from
Spencer oh Maximus Rex Kofi phenols oom
what do you think makes done to his
Divine Comedy stand out among the other
classics of the Western canon as a work
of singular genius what would you say
are its most fundamental themes and what
are the most important lessons we take
away from reading Dante since you've
quoted Dante in both Italian and English
I figured you must have carefully
studied the comedy at some point I look
forward to hearing your insights on the
poem so my basic insights are that it is
so shockingly beautiful and it is so
unified that this is what strikes me
most
you don't really catch this in the
English but he employs a scheme called
terza rima these these rhymes of three
that just very quickly the beginning of
the poem it sounds just listen to the
sounds if you don't speak Italian just
hear Nelnet so they'll come in D nostra
Vita Miri travaille para una salvos Cora
que la Drita Viera Morita I quanto a
dear koala echo Sidora as the Selva
salvages a Forte can l pensiero novella
power there's this usually you can hear
those rhymes in those sets of three so
it's very beautiful and that goes on for
a hundred Conti and also it's all
unified so instead of giving you my
thoughts on this I asked a close friend
of mine Catherine Illingworth
who is a Dante's scholar and
coincidentally was a TA of mine in
college and I asked her for her thoughts
because she's a real expert on this and
she said exactly what I think in much
better words with there are three
aspects here a universality what makes
it stand out the universality of it you
go from the depths of evil to the
heights of holiness and it touches on
all things seen and unseen of the human
condition it masters all previous art
and literature Dante is led by Virgil
Dante has drunk up and read and consumed
all of the art and culture and
literature of his time and then he
creates something original out of it
because he's totally absorbed it and
turns it into something new and because
it's so beautiful are the most
fundamental themes or that human love is
rooted in God all of it all of human
love the erotic love fraternal love love
of your friends love of the the Divine
Love all
that love from whatever you were doing
on Saturday night to whatever you were
doing Sunday afternoon is all of that is
rooted in God you see Beatrice a girl
that wasn't Dante's wife leads him to
salvation because he's following her
through to to salvation to God there's
the unity of the private and the public
so the idea here is that the world will
be orderly when people are virtuous it
won't just become peaceful and orderly
if you have vicious people or bad people
and there's a unity here of what you do
in your private life and what you do in
your public life sometimes in politics
and other works we try to divorce those
things you can't there is a unity there
is a Catholicism right there's a
universality here and there's the
relationship between love and knowledge
here so - for Dante one leads to the
other and and together they both lead to
salvation
to it - a total transformation not
following a set of rules to being
utterly transformed by divine love and
some lessons from Dante read a lot you
have to read a lot of books just like
Dante did so that you can absorb all of
that and it can really save your
civilization and save your soul another
lesson is that grace is real this is an
utterly graceful poem and you should
accept grace because it's the only
goodness it doesn't matter how lost you
are when you begin that journey what age
you begin that journey at it there's
this utter grace you see people in in
paradise who weren't always such great
people Saint John Vianney said not all
the Saints started well but they all
ended well as you see that and and that
love is always good it's a third lesson
love is always good but you shouldn't
just settle for a little piece of it
just a little fragment of love you
should follow it to its logical
conclusion Beatrice Dante finds this
girl when he's a little kid he falls in
love with her marries another woman you
know she died he's totally in love with
with Beatrice and he follows Beatrice
not to just devour Beatrice to make an
idol of his love for Beatrice but to
follow that love and allow that love to
be ennobling and lift him toward the
very heights of heaven - the love that
moves the Sun and the other stars we
could talk about Dante forever and ever
especially when I'm hearing all these
good thoughts from Kathryn Illingworth
before we get to the next question I got
to talk about another cool story so
one is gonna be really fun this is a
great narrative this is a good narrative
story and ennobling story and this one's
fun and you can listen to it in your car
I'm really excited to tell you about a
cool new show called this sounds serious
a new cast Vox creation it tells a
fictional murder story that involves
twins cults and a Florida weather man if
you are a fan of true crime shows and
comedy you will love this show this
sounds serious is out now you can listen
to it wherever you get your podcasts I
really like this cuz I don't I don't
like things that take themselves too
seriously
so I'll watch that that true-crime kind
of stuff it's always very fun you can't
turn it off
but I really like this because it's so
self-aware and very funny about it the
it's the new podcast from cast Fox this
sounds serious
the case of Daniel bronsted if you love
narrative podcasts obviously I do I in
them but you're tired of all those
serious story lines check this out
pokes fun at the mystery and crime
categories in a unique way you should
download this sounds serious
today wherever you get your podcasts it
is fake true crime that's all I like we
do fake true news here uses fake no true
fake news that I don't know something
like that this is fake true crime
delivers big on both laughs and story
really funny first two available May 1st
it is out now check it out this sounds
serious is a cast box original written
by the people behind maximum funds stop
podcasting yourself I never would do
that CBC is this is that and pan a
please Dexter guff is smarter than you
stars Peter oldring Dexter guff is
smarter than you and Carly Pope from
arrow suits and Elysium each episodes
about 25 minutes long perfect for a
commute or a road trip go to WWE
okay I've got only four minutes before
we can get to my conversation with Allie
she gives me pretty mind-blowing advice
on marriage whether or not I should run
away right now I haven't gotten married
yet I could still leave a Michael shaped
hole in the wall somewhere but let's try
to get one or two more questions in from
William dear His Holiness of the Michael
a trend among liberal hit job interviews
is to barrage conservative interviewees
with a host of
questions that are designed to
misrepresent the views of the person
being interviewed and put the onus on
them to debunk an argument that they
never make he cites the example of
Jordan Peterson who does Jordan Peterson
answers that British interviewer
perfectly reasonably and then she twists
it and tries to make him look like a
monster monster rather is it
interviewing etiquette for the person
who's being interviewed not to call the
interviewer out for nefarious tactics or
would it be smarter to hold interviewers
to their own standards before allowing
the conversation just to skip to the
next point without forcing the
interviewer to concede both the tactic
and the point I really really like that
love to show keep it co FF a William
okay yes so what they do what the left
does and the mainstream media do when
they're interviewing you
they basically ask conservatives do you
still beat your wife that is the
question they ask you do you still beat
your wife then any answer you give it's
not gonna look very good for you they
always do this so the the way to do this
now is to be a bulldog with these people
I mean be an AB hold them out on
everything be very clear
I've had many reporters call from Fox
and the New York Times or whatever and
I'm not I'm cordial to them but I'm not
nice and I don't you know I'm pretty
open with my feelings about what they do
what kind of broadly speaking what hit
jobs they do another way for
conservatives to do this is not to agree
to pre taped interviews because they
always mess those up they always mix
them up and make us look like racist
mean-spirited evil people
so don't agree to that broadly if you're
going to agree to one make sure there's
a live component to it or make sure that
you're filming them filming you that's a
real key because otherwise they're gonna
make you look awful from Tim dear Rachel
Maddow's estranged brother does Ben pay
you in shekels or cold
Tim well Ben doesn't pay me at all of
course I mean hasn't paid me in a long
time
he did give me a lump of coal for
Christmas but I like to think of that
more as a future diamond I think that
that's really been wanted to get me like
a nice big diamond ring or something and
you know I will say he just sent me a
wedding present and he got me a blender
here this is a true story really did get
me a blender and I don't know why I
don't know why when Ben thinks of me in
my future he just thinks of very sharp
blades spinning around very fast
turning formerly solid entities into
mush I don't know but it's very nice you
know I like I like the blender very much
from Kyle dear patron saint of smug
Catholics everywhere I've been hearing a
lot recently about how the American
Constitution has a somewhat Protestant
foundation to it but I'm not exactly
sure what this means could you discuss
it further
Thanks PS any tips on getting started
with cigars would be appreciated yes you
should light them that would be the the
first step to getting started with
cigars cutting them is good too but
lighting is probably the most important
one as to the question about the
Protestant foundations of America in the
Constitution there's a little truth to
that
good old Papa Knowles who came over on
the Mayflower grandpappy Samuel fuller
and the others were Protestant religious
zealots I mean they would be shocked and
horrified by the flagrant potpourri of
their progeny so if there is an aspect
of this and it manifests in a few ways
that rugged individualism that distaste
for many institutions I I will concede
that has some Protestant foundations I
will point out though that America the
americas have a catholic foundation
their don't have a protestant foundation
was Christopher Columbus a devout
wonderful serious devout charitable
wonderful brilliant fabulous terrific
Catholic man Christopher Columbus that's
a Catholic foundation so the Americas
broadly have that I think it's totally
ridiculous to say that Catholics don't
have the pioneer spirit or want to go
and spread spread the word of God and
glory and freedom to every end of the
earth if that isn't true
so yes you can concede that there's a
largely Protestant foundation in the
United States but you know this the
Americas baby that was the first one
that was the original 1492 not a
Protestant thing about it okay it's too
bad because we've got some great
questions to delve into but sadly we
just can't we just can't get to them
today I'll try to answer them I will
point out other just before we go one
person who wrote in said hey Michael I
just got my helix sleep mattress and
Boeing brand sheets in the mail today
it's quite possibly the greatest
combination in the history of the world
thank you for the mountains of coffe fa
and left us tears that i take straight
to the dome daily you're welcome i
wanted to get that little sponsor plug
in there because i sleep on them and
they are fabulous there as
Lily great so check them out they're
really really good I love them okay
that's it that's enough for today for
everybody who's on Facebook and YouTube
if you're on daily wire thank you very
much you keep Kofi Fei in my cup you
help me guzzle down delicious leftist
ears and I am mainlining them before my
wedding so go to daily wire.com you can
meet the Indra Clevenger the ben shapiro
show of questions in the mailbag blah
blah blah now that matters get the left
is tears tumblr you're gonna need it in
my absence you are gonna need it in my
absence because I'm gonna be there I'm
gonna have an ocean of mostly magma and
lava in Hawaii but wet but what you can
do is try not to drown in the leftist
tears I'm gonna avoid big magma boulders
and you can try not to drown and left us
tears go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with my interview with Ali
Stuckey
so you know alleys Stuckey alleys been
with us since the beginning alley
stopped by LA on her way I don't know
she's such a jet setter she stopped by
right before I flew out to so we talked
about the really important things
because after this folks the next time
you see me I'm gonna be about fifty
pounds heavier
probably sweaty or unshaven you know
pushing a lawnmower in the suburbs
somewhere ten kids around me I'm getting
married okay
that's what I'm saying I got a little
advice from a least uh key on it on that
and many other topics here is my
interview with Allie Stuckey Allie it's
good to see you Michael it's great to
see you so listen we're on a time
constraint here yeah
Allie has a flight in about 17 hours so
you have to leave for LAX right now I'm
LA scares me the traffic is horrific I I
just I'm worried and I don't know LAX
and so I just have to make sure that I
get there on time you know I do this I
this is a I know you're intend to do a
Praeger video part of it talks about
sexual differences between men and women
yes this is a sexual difference between
men and women the airport arrival time
yeah I I go I was going back to New York
for Christmas this was Christmas week I
showed up 35 minutes before departure
not before boarding or chat just before
departure I made it it was fine plus you
know you got that pre check the
pre-check is the greatest invention but
you just never know and I feel like
people in California are just kind of
crazy there's some predictable there
it's very unpredictable
it is also they're the worst drivers in
the country yes that's the problem
sweet little ELISA does this too though
we'll be flying you know domestically
and she'll say you know man we need to
leave four and a half hours before we
get there impression I'm sure that your
fiancee doesn't say what you mean it's
horrible like it is inaccurate er no I
don't know how she sounds but I hope she
doesn't sound like it 85 year old hag
how dare you call my fiancee an 85 year
old hag for me I'm just saying you might
want to nail the impersonation before
you leave for the honeymoon suite little
ELISA got very upset because I did this
podcast with Drew another Kingdom where
I play
all the characters in I know I listen to
oh it's great
so I told sweet little lace I said your
voice and by your voice I mean the voice
that I have created for you it plays a
role in one of the characters she goes
oh is it that pretty character Jane said
no it's a rat woman it's a mutant rat
Mac it's not it's not you're writing
your own vows are you worried we're
gonna get up there and then I'm just
gonna do the bass for her I do she has a
long a long life of suffering ahead of
her but it'll be well [ __ ] she knows
what she's getting herself into
now on the topic of marriage yes a big
marriage proponent you've been married
you were selling fake marriage what if I
said I wasn't that would be really
troubling I would yeah well that I'm
trying to get advice from all corners
here before I make this major life
decision well you've already made the
decision my friend so you should stick
to it no marriage is awesome it's the
best thing that I've ever done best best
second best decision I've ever made
after following Christ and I love it I
mean it really is I know it's so cliche
everyone's like oh you get to marry your
best friend but it's really true I mean
what could be better than going home and
being like I get to hang out with the
person that I always want to be with all
the time the only person that I really
want to talk to the only person I really
want to spend time with and watch
Netflix with them really what is better
than that I love all of that and I agree
entirely with that sentiment but I do
have to ask because I hear this and I
only hear this from girls the marry your
best friend thing is that come on yeah
you don't think so I I mean he's he's my
best friend
now I love my other friends but he is my
best friend he's the person that I want
to spend time with all the time but when
I don't you think there's a categorical
difference like when I think of my best
friend I think of you know going out and
smoking cigars and you know carousing
and I don't know doing whatever guys do
you know I think I guess maybe it is a
girl thing I think of my best friend is
someone who I can be my most genuine
self with all the time and there are
just no barriers that's how I feel about
the best friend but you know you have a
different mentality about and it is true
I mean practically speaking your your
wife will be your best friend you that
you hang out with that person all the
time you know each other backwards
four words you know yeah that's true I
can't get it you know when I just think
of that though it's now you'll figure it
in masculine when I oh my gosh no you'll
love it marriage is awesome
now did you see there's a new comment
out by a a I computer scientist the guy
who invented that robot that looks a lot
like a woman you know and it's like
really uncanny and scary he says that we
will be his name as a Victor David no
David Victor I confuse him with Victor
Davis Hanson anyway whatever his name is
dr. so-and-so he says that we will be
marrying robots by 2045 is I wonder one
if that's gonna happen I mean we're
already having sex with robots that
already exists in 2018 I'm using wheat
loosely by the way we're gonna edit that
out and post that already exists do you
do you see the culture moving in that
direction I'm only half kidding do you
think there will be a time when we're
marrying artificial intelligence robots
I think I think probably I think
probably so I mean we've already
devalued and cheapened marriage so much
to the point to where it's just this
kind of this transaction where you do it
for a little bit if it works out where
it's more like a contract that we sign
it if you want to break it you can get
out of it that kind of thing we've
already devalued it and cheapen it so
much that I have a hard time believing
that humans have some kind of moral
limit that we won't get to the point of
objectifying or cheapening marriage that
much to we're marrying artificial
intelligence I would love to think that
we do I would love to think that deep in
the human heart something's just gonna
wake up and say no that's not a real
person but I will tell you that if the
robots are anything like they are in
West world it will be very very
difficult to actually distinguish that's
true because okay this is another gender
difference
have you watched Westworld I know my
only experience of Westworld is the star
of Westworld the blonde girl Dolores
Evan Rachel Wood Evan Rachel Wood
started a Twitter fight with me she was
angry about something I said yeah and so
I didn't know who she was I said oh
pretty little actress okay I'll respond
she's being very mean and I was being
very respectful and then at the end she
said something else mean and then she
blocked me that's my old
soured on Westworld right now those
robots are me I know I blame it on the a
oh yeah okay so here's a gender
difference that's interesting with
Westworld and I'll turn tie back into
what we were actually talking about so
season one you know that all the
artificial intelligence that they're
robots all the guys in my life all the
people that I know that watch Westworld
we all love season one together
season two I still liked season two the
girlfriends that I have liked season two
no guy that I know that watched season
one like season two and I think the
reason is because they start to blur the
lines between the robots and the humans
to where you don't know anymore if who's
a robot and who's not I don't mind that
because to me I have a soft spot for the
robots like they feel thanks too but all
the guy is in my life they're like what
the heck they're robots I don't really
care if they get murdered I don't care
if they get killed so I just think
that's interesting and I wonder if that
mentality will be true to win
what if that'll be true when artificial
intelligence starts infiltrating our
lives if there will be a different
perception between men and women of
robots that yeah I wonder about that
because women are just nicer and more
pleasant and more nurturing generally
and men yeah they're a little colder you
know they're not as nurturing toward
babies or animals and are very
sentimental so you don't really
sentimentalize a robot or something like
that yeah I mean we've already got so
much of them in our in our homes you
know the government spying on us through
Alexa and all of that I I'm so abusive
to Alexa I am like if Alexa has rights
in the in 2045 I'm getting booked and
going to jail that's scary for what I
know I want to talk about work okay I
want to talk it you know there's
marriage and there's work yeah that's
how you says marriages work they say the
there is a new study out that the number
one cause of long-term poverty in
America is not working I know this is
shocking I know
I didn't want to do that to you just
before you're about to get on a flight
what yeah that is the number one cause
so the statistics that are being cited
here 82% of people on food stamps are
able-bodied adults 3800 I think it's 32
percent of them 32 or 38 or working at
all not full-time
just part-time a couple hours here and
there at all the vast majority of them
are not working one little bit how do we
resolve this problem how do we how do we
you know because we have this very
sentimental view of it we say all these
poor people we need to spend more money
from the government more food stamps
more whatever they're just not working
but why would they work when they
probably make more money off of the
government they probably lose some money
by getting a job when I spoke at UC
Berkeley we had someone that drove for
hours to come here our little panel and
he was telling me his story afterwards
how he used to be homeless and now he
has a job and he has a lot of friends
who are still homeless who don't
understand why he transitioned from
homelessness to having a job just
because it's so much harder having a job
and he's like it is I make less money
than I did when I was homeless
oh my isn't that crazy and so I I think
it's abuse of the welfare system it
really is it more lucrative to not have
a job these days than to have one
sometimes it depends on what kind of job
you can get I guess I remember John
Stossel did one of these you know sting
things and he went out and dressed up
like a bum and begged for money and then
he annualized his income and tried to
figure out how much he could make and it
was something like 90 grand a year
tax-free or something it's pretty good
you know so insane so that's why I think
like when ben Carson has said this and
he's gotten you know he's gotten so much
flack for it that a lot of times poverty
is a mentality not in all cases
certainly not in all cases but a lot of
times it is and I honestly don't know
how you shake someone out of that it's
almost like Stockholm Syndrome long-term
poverty it certainly is a mentality I
mean people you know in economies people
fall on hard times right for a period of
time but long-term poverty certainly is
a choice right you know do you saw this
story about the Millennial the 30 year
old kid the 30 there's a 30 year old kid
he has a kid you know he's a dad oh and
he's a daddy
he's a 30 year old kid he has his own
son is living in his parents house they
beg him to leave or get a job or do
anything five times they ask him send
him notices they finally have to take
him to court to do it is this a
millennial that you know the Millennials
are the I mean Millennials part of
your Christian name I believe
conservative millennial the it's a
much-maligned group the Millennials get
a lot of flack these days is it all
deserved in this case absolutely but I
don't know if it's the fact that she is
a millennial and he's like really kind
of on the edge of millenials anyway I
think that you have deadbeats in every
generation this guy is just a deadbeat
guy I do think it's probably a trend in
Millennials were certainly more entitled
we don't know the value of the dollar as
much as our parents did just because a
lot of us didn't have to but I think
it's something like a third of
Millennials still live at home which
again is not always a bad thing I have
friends that who are now very successful
who had to live at home right after
college but it's this perpetual
adolescence and this prolonged
immaturity that we see among Millennials
that scares me
those are the people that are voting for
Bernie Sanders that's true I will say it
is a little rich of me I'm about to go
on a three day long bachelor party to be
talking about irresponsibility and
carousing and things but yeah that that
that does seem to be certainly the case
I want to ask you before I let you go
because you're an expert on Millennials
you're an expert on marriage now having
done it and you you're also an expert on
Christianity
now listen expert but you talk about it
a lot you're a practicing Christian and
you know I'm not going to pull out the
squirt gun of Catholic holy water and
spray you and try to bring you back home
to Mother Church I've had enough
potpourri on the show recently what I do
want to know though evangelicals have
been getting a lot of flack recently -
mmm this week has been a rough week for
evangelicals it's been a tough week for
evangelicals and I want to know
specifically evangelicals are being
called hypocrites for supporting Trump
there was that big piece in the Atlantic
last month by Michael Gerson I think how
they sold their soul to support Trump I
don't understand these arguments at all
what do you make of them because you
know listen I'm a Catholic so we're we
have a little more loosey-goosey view on
some of these things you know yeah so
that's a good way to describe
what is your take on that on the
hypocrisy the alleged hypocrisy of
evangelicals who support Donald right
it's only hypocritical if you're saying
simultaneously oh actually having sex
with a porn star while you're married is
totally fine and over here saying
adultery is wrong but I don't see and
I'm not saying no easy angelical czar
doing that but even Robert Jeffress who
has been quite a mouthpiece for Donald
Trump and I don't agree with everything
he has said in favor of Donald Trump but
even he has said you know we still stand
where we stand morally we don't think
it's okay to have sex with a porn chart
we don't think it's okay to cheat on
your wife but he is the most pro-life
president that we've ever had moving the
embassy to Jerusalem is a big deal to
them even things like deregulation and
promoting capitalism is a big deal to
Protestants Protestantism and capitalism
really have gone hand in hand
since the Protestant Reformation so we
have these values that we feel like
Donald Trump is promoting and I do think
it's important that we say hey we
disagree with a lot of the personal
moral choices that he's made and we can
hold him accountable for that but at the
same time we support him actually
advancing our agenda whereas under
Barack Obama we felt like there was a
lot of antipathy towards evangelicals
and so we didn't support him do you
think there was antipathy because he
said that they're all bible-thumping gun
clinging ingrates and idiots basically
and then he painted the White House in
rainbow colors just cuz a little bit of
that and Lois Lerner maybe just like a
little bit of that so yeah I think I
think that's probably what is I think
they more see him and I don't want to
objectify him but they almost see him as
a tool to advance our agenda and a
useful tool to advance our agenda more
than they see him as a Ronald Reagan
some stalwart of Christian values I
think we all know that he's no choirboy
but I think it's important also for
evangelical leaders to make that
distinction and to say that and maybe
they haven't done a good job of that but
to say it's hypocritical everyone is
hypocritical everyone holds personal
values that probably differ from any
politician I would hope so that all the
people that voted for Hillary Clinton
don't think that all the things that
she's done in her life are morally okay
I kill that guy
I don't know I'm not making any so I I
just I just think it's silly it's just
it's just a way for them once again to
virtue signal to say there's no way that
you can either be a religious or a good
person and vote for Donald Trump and
that's just not true yeah absolutely
right well said I gotta let you get out
of here yeah you're on CR TV you're the
stuff you're putting out is fabulous
it's really really good
where can people find you so my podcast
is every Wednesday it's called relatable
you can find out iTunes SoundCloud all
of that obviously on Wednesdays you have
to listen to my show and Michaels show
at the same time you can't replace
simultaneous yes stream them yes it'll
just sound like this so you can find me
there you can find me on CR tv.com
sometimes I'm on TV with Michael Knowles
that's true the other day so yeah all
over the place social media you can find
me there too what's your Twitter it's
conserved millennial is that I can't but
you can just look at the Allie Stuckey I
think I'm I think fabulous Allie always
good to see you yes we don't run you
down to LAX now really good advice
conserve my land what it is so I won't
one I I want a cool millennial nickname
like Coke cough cough cough FMLN like
all the millennial you know the
Millennial companies are like there are
two words smashed together and random
capitalization and all that that's what
yeah that's what I want so LEM on
honeymoon please figure that out for me
because I you know I already spent all
the blank book money I need I need
something else to pay for this honeymoon
it's very nice to be able to say goodbye
to you guys for the next week I'll be
gone if I don't get swallowed up by
sharks or lava or magma I will see you
again soon
next time as a much fatter and more
suburban married a man probably with
lots of children by that in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show I'll see
in a week
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua Elvira the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018